[Musique]
après deux années de disette dû à la
crise sanitaire les touristes étrangers
ont rapporté 58 milliards d'euros en
2022 la France un chiffre qui bat le
précédent record de plus d'un milliard
dans les Yvelines le château de
Versailles et le site touristique qui a
attiré le plus de touristes en 2022 avec
6,9 millions de visiteurs un chiffre
néanmoins en baisse de 16% par rapport à
2019 les touristes étrangers viennent
principalement des États-Unis d'Italie
d'Allemagne les visiteurs asiatiques
n'ont pas encore fait leur grand retour
la Corée du Sud premier pays d'Asie dans
le classement ne représente que 3% de la
fréquentation du site en 2022 la SNCF
recrute en 2023 plus de 900 agents
seront recrutés cette année par
Transilien SNCF voyageur dont 400
conducteurs de train RER et de tram
train et 200 chargés de la relation
client en gare de forums de recrutement
seront lancés en mars et en avril par
Transilien en Île-de-France SNCF
voyageur représente 6000 trains qui
circulent chaque jour dans la région
francilienne
si vous habitez saint-jean-en-laye que
vous êtes éloigné de l'emploi mais avec
un projet de création d'entreprise la
ruche peut vous aider le réseau national
d'incubateurs d'entreprise lance pour la
troisième année consécutive son
programme le coup d'envoi lui permettra
plusieurs lauréats d'être accompagné
pendant 6 mois gratuitement à la
création d'entreprise vous avez jusqu'au
12 mars prochain pour déposer vos
candidatures les inscriptions sont
désormais close 12600 sportifs
participeront la 16e édition de
l'écoterelle de Paris le 18 mars
prochain au programme 5 traits les deux
marches nordiques les preuves phare le
80 km partira de l'île de loisirs de 50
ans en Yvelines pour rejoindre le
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel mauvaise
opération pour le FC Versailles les
joueurs de la cité royale se sont
inclinés 1-0 sur leur pelouse face à
Concarneau le but a été inscrit en fin
de match par faheid El koumisti versa
également terminé la rencontre à 10
suite au carton rouge de Gustave
aquessen au classement les ivinois
perdent la première place au profit de
Martigues
[Musique]